It's time for Drew's News.
Your joy ride down Good News Falls,
and with me at the desk is two besties
I'd love to hop in a barrel
and float on down the river with,
it's Cameron Auntie Poopoo Diaz.
(audience cheers)
and Rossy Ross Matthews!
And together they make Auntie Rossy Poo.
(laughs)
Poopoo, I want to dedicate this segment to you.
When I was trying to basically, let's face it,
it was an audition, and I really felt strongly
about this particular segment.
It was very personal for me,
but to convince everybody of this idea,
I had to put it in the sales tape and sell this segment.
So of course,
I'm gonna take you back to that audition sales tape.
Let's look back at the very first Drew's News in history.
The one thing I don't like doing with you is hiking,
because you have these giant great, like, German shepherds
and you have these long leg,
you are a great Dane,
and I have these short dogs and the legs of a corgi dog.
And I literally can't keep up with you.
No it's a kind of a comedy act and she's like,
(heaving breathing)
she's like seething, her face, she's just so angry at me.
I know.
I have to stop every five seconds.
I'm like, come on,
let's go, what's the matter?
It's like a gazelle and an armadillo.
That's what us hiking looks like.
(audience cheers)
So, thank you for helping me convince
everyone of this segment.
My pleasure, my pleasure!
(audience cheers)
It was a hard sell.
And, you know,
I also think when it came to that banter,
that comradery,
that bouncing off each other,
talking about the news stories and then sharing feelings
and opinions about it,
when you're alone you don't have anyone to do that with.
So Rossy Ross Matthews,
thank god, showed up and saved a girl.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)